- If it doesn't have a face,
if it never had a face, would you eat it?
- My name is Sara and I'm a
video producer here at Buzzfeed
and I just found out about lab grown meat.
So if you're like me, you're
thinking wait what is that?
- What is it called?
Is it like real meat?
- Quick explainer.
Lab grown meat is actual meat,
but they didn't slaughter
an animal to get it.
- I guess it's like
cloned meat or something?
- It's originally from
like an animal cell right,
so they have to get something
from an animal to then grow.
- Stem cells are taken from an animal
and then they're grown in a culture.
The cells multiply until
they become muscle tissue.
- This looks like
somebody's getting pregnant.
- That muscle tissue is what forms meat.
Some of this sounds very
cool and sci-fi, right?
But what are the benefits
of lab grown meat?
According to the UN, meat consumption
is expected to rise as
much as 73% by 2050.
- Means we have like a
huge global food problem
and so you know if it helps
solve that then awesome.
- Growing meat in labs could
reduce greenhouse gases by 96%
compared to traditional livestock farms.
Are all of the benefits
from lab grown meat enough
to convince a vegetarian
or vegan to try it?
- I was raised without
any red meat or pork,
so I think it would make me pretty sick.
- My stomach would immediately reject it
and I would just vomit, so probably not.
- Don't want to eat
meat anyway whether it's
from an animal or grown in a lab.
- Yeah I don't think I stopped eating meat
because of the cruelty.
I miss chicken, I miss cheese,
I miss all these things,
I just my stomach can't
tolerate it anymore.
- I think it's taking something from them
that we don't need to take
away and why do we need to take
a animal cell to then grow a burger
if we have so many plant based options?
- For a lot of vegetarians and vegans,
it doesn't matter it's lab grown meat.
They're not interested in meat period.
But for the meat eaters,
there are also some concerns.
- I would probably try it, lab grown meat.
It's a little bit weird.
- I would try it once, you know,
'cause I think I would
try everything once.
- But I guess it's no weirder
than eating like an actual animal.
- Look, you cook it, I'll eat it.
- The fact that we eat animals
is a little weird anyway,
'cause they're just like,
they're not that different from people.
Why do I eat meat?
- If I knew that it was grown
in a lab I would still eat it.
I have no standards when it comes to food.
- I would be down as long as
they can prove it's not a carcinogen.
As long as like 30 years from now people
aren't growing arms out of
their heads or something.
- It depends on how expensive it is.
- I wouldn't pay more money to eat food
that was grown in a lab just
because it didn't kill any animals.
I'm broke.
- Yeah lab grown meat
it sounds pretty fancy.
It has to be expensive right?
Like how much does it cost?
- The current hamburger has costed
250,000 euro which is quite a lot.
- Dr. Mark Post's lab grown hamburger
cost $331,000 to produce in 2013
but the prices have
gone down substantially
in the past few years and
by 2023 Dr. Mark Post hopes
that you'll be buying lab grown
meat at supermarket prices.
- If it tastes good and it looks like
they're doing it responsibly,
I have no problems with it.
- Hell yeah I'd eat lab grown meat.
That sounds dope.
Meat's delicious, everyone knows that
unless you're not into meat.
- There is quite some
flavor with the browning
and I know there is no fat in it,
so I didn't really know how
it's, how juicy it will be.
- Lab grown meat lacks the fat
from traditional livestock,
so unless you're super into lean meat,
the taste might not be your thing.
- But there is quite some intense taste.
It's close to meat, it's not that juicy.
- The good news is that
scientists are experimenting
on ways to add healthy
fats into lab grown meat
so you can get that
juicy taste you desire.
♫ Mm juicy taste
But the bottom line is
if I walked up to you
with a hamburger, that was
made out of lab grown meat,
would you try it?
- Man if this lab grown
meat thing works out,
it would be very exciting.
I mean I love--
- One Earth, one people, so people
make it in a lab.
- That's true.
What was your question?